There is this event that happens where
everyone from the entire world, think
about this biblically,
people from all over the entire world,
different nations, different politicians
from different nation nations, all
gather together in one place for a
certain event, and it's supposed to be
about sports. It's supposed to be about
athletics,
and instead,
you get to witness an opening ceremony,
a ritual. Why is there always a ceremony
when you go to watch a sporting event,
whether it's the Super Bowl or the
Olympics? Why is there always a
ceremony?
We're going to look into what that word
means. I'm not just making this word up.
It is a It is literally called an
opening ceremony. You can look up the
articles. It says, "The Winter Olympics
opening ceremony." There's also a reason
why it's held in the winter. This is all
about bringing back the sun.
The pagan traditions, the pagan rituals
are about when
death is happening in the wintertime,
they had the promise of the evergreen
tree. This is why you have this at at
Christmas time and stuff. It's about uh
sun worship. It's about a promise that
the sun will return when everything
seems to be dying and death is
everywhere.
But you see, this is called an opening
ceremony. Why is that so important?
What's What's the big deal about a
ceremony? Well, by definition, a
ceremony is a formal religious occasion.
Notice the second one says, "The
ritual." So, it is literally a religious
ritual. That's what a ceremony is. So,
why are people sitting around thousands
in the stadium
participating in a religious ritual
while millions around the world are
consenting to this and applauding it and
being entertained by it for for days.
This thing goes on while the entire
world is consenting to this. Think about
how deep that is on a spiritual level
because like we've talked about, Satan
can only do what he's allowed to do. He
has to play by the rules and he has to
have consent. We have to give him an
open door. So, when we are watching
these things, we are consenting. And no,
I did not watch it at all. I skimmed
through to find exactly what I was
looking for and I'm never watching this
garbage. This is going to be a dance
where you see an angel lighting up and
he doesn't look very holy, does he? He's
got this
kind of dark countenance about him and
all around him you see these people that
are dressed in gray.
I don't want this to get flagged. I'm
going to skim through here. Um, they're
supposed to represent these statues.
Notice these busts that are all around.
These are Greek gods that are the bust.
And you see this angel. The only focus
is an angel and a woman.
And the angel, he's looking for his
victim.
And he goes into the box where he sees
this woman. Think of the Garden of Eden.
And he begins to seduce her.
And these
gods that were that looked like these
gray gods have awakened and they're
dancing around. And now he's dancing
with the woman.
And you'll see that he begins to possess
her. He's the one in control as you see
this strange thing happening right here.
What was that?
Did you notice?
The one eye symbolism. This is not
normal, guys. This isn't just like, oh,
that would be an interesting thing if I
covered my eye with my hand. This is
giving their allegiance. They are
signaling to the entire watching world,
"We are Satanists. We are Luciferian and
we are summoning our savior." Um, in
that arena was bust of Mithra, Mitra.
And you can see on the right, that's an
actual bust of Mithra. Who is he? In
Greco-Roman syncretism, particularly
during the 1st century BCE to 4th
century CE, the Persian deity Mithra was
frequently equated or combined with the
Greek god Apollo, as well as Helios and
Hermes as a singular powerful solar
deity. This is all about sun worship.
You're going to see it over and over.
This is all about sun worship, like I
just got through saying. There was a
scientist who had interaction with CERN
scientists, and they were admitting to
her that CERN is a portal that has
allowed a deity to come through and sit
at their table and leave a scarf and
take a scarf and all kinds of crazy
stuff. And CERN was when it was first
built, they had these meetings at
Apollo's temple. Why is everything
revolving around Apollo? Sun worship,
these ritualistic dances trying to
summon something into our world,
manifest. This is what's been going on
for years now, and
uh an occultist named Alice Bailey wrote
a book called
The Externalization of the Hierarchy,
and she predicted, because she was a
channeler, she was told by Satan and his
fallen angels that in the year 2025
would be the externalization of the
hierarchy, that it would be a gradual
procession where spiritual entities
would begin to manifest in our world.
And now we are building,
you know, using our technology for evil
to open up portals for demonic entities
to come into our world and have these
ceremonies where literally the entire
world is gathering together in one place
and doing a ritualistic dance to summon
the sun god. This is This There's goes
deeper. Watch this. How are they going
to signal
right in front of people unless they
kind of disguise it, right? So, we
already saw the one eye symbolism. Now,
you have this woman come out and she's
going to pretend to be um struggling
with sign language.
And And the first sign you'll see is one
that you probably all That's interesting
little move there. Kind of a serpentine
wiggle there.
And then she The first sign she does is
what?
The 666 sign, right?
Perfect. She does the 666 hand sign.
Then,
as she continues,
she says it's not working. She's doing
some other hand signs.
She's praying, good heavens.
And then what does she do? Look at this.
Why is she doing the horns? Upside down
the horns.
This is all signaling. They're telling
you who they serve. And then there's
cussing going on.
So, I just want to show you that this
There's nothing decent or innocent about
this
ceremony that they're literally telling
you is a ceremony. Now, here is a video
where
they're taking you They're walking you
through history.
And so, it's taking you through a
timeline and this is following this
woman.
And you know, it's going through the
'50s and the '60s and all that.
And then it finally gets to the end here
where she looks kind of futuristic
and she runs out onto the stage. Now,
what is going on with the stage? This is
a portal.
This is And notice the center looks like
a swastika. That's on purpose because
that is an ancient symbol of the sun.
Again,
notice the colors that are represented
here. It's all blue right now.
Right now, it's blue, but that's going
to change and it's all for a purpose.
So, the stage looks like a portal.
They're doing the ritualistic dances.
And I hope I have it on the next scene
here. Maybe it's here. Listen to what
they say is right here about what
they're about to do.
Trip through the last century of the
Winter Games on our way eventually to
the lighting of the cauldrons. The
lighting of the cauldrons.
But they're So, right now the stage is
blue. It's this portal with a symbol of
the sun in the middle. Again, sun
worship.
And they're about to light the
cauldrons, they said.
All right. Now, here's the next scene as
we see a little girl looking at the sun.
She's literally hypnotized by the sun.
Are you guys seeing the pattern? This is
not just me making something out of
nothing. I can't make something out of
nothing. She's literally gazing at the
sun. And then one of the one of these uh
female astronauts come out. What does an
astronaut have to do with the Olympics?
I'm confused here. Was this the ISS? Is
this
the Olympics or what is this?
It's all propaganda. This whole
brainwashing about oh, be obsessed with
space and the planets and the sun is so
huge and look how big it is on this
model.
And so, in even you hear the little
girl, she's talking about oh, you know,
50 billion years ago the sun was built
so or created. So,
there again, propaganda propaganda of
evolution.
And so, the astronaut lady leads her to
this stage and she's mesmerized. She's
looking around oh, and the the swirling
portal.
And notice you see the Saturn rings on
the Everybody is dressed in the rings of
Saturn.
All of this is paganism, planetary
worship. And then the girl runs out to
the center all happily
right into the center of
this portal. Now, notice things are
starting to change. The colors are
turning red. We're going to look into
what is the reason of this blue to red
shift that's happening at this ceremony.
Where did this ceremony happen? It
happened at the Arch of Peace in Italy,
and it has Apollo
engraved on the archway. Now, these
archways aren't just these beautiful um
pieces of artistic expression. There is
a purpose for them. If you look into the
definition of what these things are, I
can do it real quick on the fly. Let's
check it out. Arch constructions hold
deep spiritual significance across
cultures, symbolizing thresholds between
the temporal and divine worlds, strength
and transformation. It's always about
transformation, rising out of the ashes,
shifting from the old order to the new
order. They act as symbolic doorways to
sacred spaces, representing the
transition from the profane to the holy,
often evoking themes of rebirth. That's
the whole phoenix rising out of the
ashes, protection, and the journey
towards higher transcendent reality.
Keep this in mind because this is going
to occur over and over and over in this
presentation, a transcending to a higher
de-
uh state of consciousness.
So, these archways that are all over the
world that we're about to get one in DC
called the Arc of Trump, and it's the
same thing. It This is a doorway
inviting spirit- spiritual entities into
our world. This is what's about to
happen in very short time. We are about
to get rid of the human politicians of
the world because the Epstein files are
coming out. We're finding out
everybody's corrupt. We're losing faith
in everything, and we are about to be
ruled by spiritual entities. That's
what's about to happen. That's what the
externalization of the hierarchy is.
This is where this ceremony was held.
It's about bringing spiritual beings
into a physical realm and it's about
ascending. You're going to keep seeing
that over and over. Listen again about
the cauldron.
The sign of that cauldron. So there
under the archway you see the light
bearer. He represents Lucifer holding
the torch and who is What is he doing?
He's taking it to the man and the woman.
This is not just pulled out of a hat.
This is all symbolic. This represents
Adam and Eve. This represents humanity
as a whole and he's going to give them
the torch.
And why did they just call it a
cauldron? They're lighting this
cauldron. What does a cauldron
symbolize? I didn't even use the word
occult, witchcraft, anything. What does
a cauldron symbolize? Uh it symbolizes
transformation, rebirth, divine
feminine, all these things that are
being pushed on us in this current era.
Acting as a vessel it says it's uh to
destroy or change. We're going to
destroy this old order and bring in the
new order. It's a Celtic myth They do it
in Celtic mythology and witchcraft. It's
a element of water. We talked about that
in the CERN video that everything is
about water right now and fire.
And it's has to do with alchemical
change, meaning changing one element
into another.
Lead into gold. You Look this stuff up.
This is uh the scientific world says
that they have figured out alchemy now
and they can turn lead into gold and
Trump's saying we're in the golden age
and Alice Bailey's saying that we're in
the age of Aquarius. All this stuff is
happening right now.
This is real. And so he hands the torch
to the man and the woman.
And this is kind of a slow process right
here, but they begins to ascend and I
was watching I was like, "Why is this
taking so long?" This is not just like
they don't have enough technology or
hydraulics or whatever. This is
purposeful. This is a ceremony like they
say, it's a ritual. Why is this man and
this woman
slowly ascending up to this star? I see
a blue circle with a a star inside. It's
a pentagram.
And it's facing upright. Notice the
color is blue. The occult symbolism of
ascending like they were doing is about
the soul's journey towards higher
consciousness, divine union, and
transcendence of the ego. It's a shift
from the material attachments to
spiritual awakening and enlightenment,
moving from a lower denser state to a
lighter higher vibrational state. This
is going to
The the evidence is building. We're
talking about transcendence. We're
talking about summoning a solar deity.
We're talking about
um ascending and awakening and
enlightening and moving from the old
order to the new order
through this higher vibrational state.
Everything in everything at the opening
ceremony was just that.
So they finally make it to the top. They
stick the torch in the cauldron. That's
what they called it. I don't know why
it's called a cauldron, but there's the
fire happening. And what happens? It
turns red. It it it grows and expands.
And then what does it look like?
I don't have to tell you what that is a
symbol of.
I hope not. It should be pretty obvious.
That is clearly an inverted pentagram.
And so what is the what does it mean to
transition from blue to red in the
occult? It's the It's again, this is
about alchemy.
It's a fundamental shift from mental
passive or heavenly states. Think about
Lucifer was in heaven, right? Into a
active, physical, and transformative
power. So, we're talking about
spiritualness coming into the physical.
And at the bottom you see it says, "Or
the spirit realm
while uh so blue represents the
rational, intellectual, or spiritual
realm while red represents the physical,
passionate, and instinctual body. The
shift from blue to red symbolizes
bringing divine or mental ideas into
tangible earthly existence."
This is all about manifestation,
bringing spiritual entities manifest
into our physical world. That is soon to
come and everything is pointing to that
in prophecy and esoteric writings.
You can see the inverted pentagram
right there under the archway
with fireworks blowing off and they're
painting the whole archway red. It went
from blue to red.
And here's an up-close picture where you
can see the clear inverted pentagram
just like on the image right here on the
right. This isn't a reach, this isn't a
stretch, this isn't making something out
of nothing, this is exactly what is
happening and they're not even hiding it
anymore because Satan doesn't have to
hide. He's been desensitizing us over
the years through entertainment, making
it look like fun and oh witchcraft is
cool, Harry Potter, all this stuff to
the point where now they can have a a
ritualistic ceremony televised to
millions of people around the world and
nobody bats an eye. And we are all
consenting to yes, we consent
for Satan to be our new Christ, our
Messiah, to enter into our world and we
will embrace you because
the whole structure's collapsing and
we're all desperate for a savior.
And here you see that astronaut lady
giving the sun to the little girl in the
middle of the symbol of the sun portal
as the ritualistic dancers are dancing
around with the rings of Saturn.
This is so in your face it's crazy.
As you can see, the swastika is not just
this symbol of hate that Hitler made it.
This symbol has existed for It's one of
the oldest known symbols in history.
And it's found all over the world, not
just in Germany, not just in Asia, all
over the world, and it represents the
sun. And that's exactly what you see
this little girl standing on, the
swastika sun symbol portal. The ceremony
ended with Mariah Carey, and they're and
they're bringing her in, and
uh Aubrey did an episode about
frequencies and music and how these high
frequencies actually put you in a
trance-like state, and it's used in the
occult to
summon deities,
and it's
it's called a siren. This is a siren
practice of witchcraft, and here she is
televised to millions doing that call.
And so here you'll see it says uh yes,
within occult, shaman shamanic, and
esoteric traditions, singing, including
high-pitched vocalizations, chanting, or
shrill sounds is used as a technique to
invoke, summon, or communicate with
deities and spirits. Sound is believed
to create specific vibrations that can
alter consciousness and bridge the gap
between the physical and spiritual
realms. That's what's happening. That's
what she's doing. And thousands of
people are are willfully there being
entertained by this siren as she's doing
the ritual summoning
these beings, putting everyone in a
trance, and connecting
the gap between the physical and
spiritual realm. Shamanic and ritual
use, shamanic practitioners often use
specific, often high-pitched or
repetitive, you just heard both.
She did that
uh scream over and over and over. Chance
to summon guardian spirits or power
animals. Similarly,
in some traditions, high-pitched sounds
are used to attract or commune with
specific entities. Vibrational
frequency, occult studies often posit
that different musical notes and pitches
correspond to different energetic
frequencies. High-pitched sounds are
sometimes used to raise energy or
correspond with specific spiritual,
elemental, or divine forces.
Ritual tools in Wiccan and ceremonial
magic, high-pitched instruments like
bells and chimes are frequently used to
invoke the goddess or other deities as
these sounds are believed to banish
negative and banish negativity and
create an atmosphere suitable for divine
presence. Chanting and mantra mantras,
repetitive sustained high-pitched
vocalizations are used to enter trance
states allowing the practitioner to
connect with or summon the presence of a
deity. So, we're seeing the same
repetitious thing, right? We're seeing
the same pattern over and over that this
is all about reaching a higher state of
consciousness, summoning a deity into
our present realm,
and getting everyone in the audience to
to uh
to consent to that and agree with that.
And listen to the words that she says at
the end of this song.
>> [music]
>> Nothing is impossible. Nothing is
impossible. She keeps re- repeating this
phrase over and over and over about
nothing is impossible.
And it made me think immediately of
Genesis and the Tower of Babel. Do
people from all over the world come to
this Olympics ceremony? Yes. The
Olympics strive to unite the world's
nations in a single spirit of
friendship, solidarity, and fair play,
acting as a rare, temporary pause in
global geopolitical divisions. While the
games promote peace, they do not
eliminate political tension entirely,
though they foster mutual respect and
inclusion.
So, the whole
object of this these games that are
played, and you can go to olympics.com.
We did a video specifically on the
Olympics, and on their website, they
will tell you the origin of the
Olympics. These are games to Apollo.
They're ritualistic games to appease
Apollo. Over and over, we just keep
seeing Apollo. And it says the Olympic
the Olympic truce, based on ancient
tradition,
this initiative urges the peaceful
settlement of conflicts with the UN
with the UN recognizing the games as a
symbol of tolerance and cooperation. It
even gets into the symbol like unity of
the five rings representing the
inhabited continents feature colors
found in nearly all national flags
symbolizing global unity.
So, what does this take us to?
The Tower of Babel, where all nations
came together in unity.
And was it good or was it bad? Did God
say, "Oh, I'm so glad that all the world
is united together in peace." No, read
the story.
They all came together, and they did
this wicked act of building a tower to
heaven because they said, "We don't need
God. We don't need your laws. We'll get
to heaven ourself. We'll build a tower
to heaven, just like Satan said, 'I will
ascend to the heights of the cloud. I
don't need you, God. I can do it on my
own.'"
And what does God say in Genesis 11:6?
It says, "And the Lord said, 'Behold,
the people is one, and they have all one
language.
And this they begin to do. And now
nothing will be restrained from them
which they have imagined to do.
Nothing is impossible.
That's what Mariah Carey was singing
as she was
singing these high-pitched notes
repetitively, putting the audience in a
trance.
The whole world is uniting together,
consenting
at this ritualistic ceremony
where everything about it was
symbolizing the sun deity coming into
our world
and we're welcoming and ushering in that
deity. I hope this was eye-opening to
you. If it was, please give it a thumbs
up. It really helps get this video out
into the algorithm. Please share this
with family and friends because a lot of
people just have no clue. They're
watching this stuff because it's just
entertainment, it's tradition, whatever.
Let them see the truth because we are in
the last days and it's time to stop
playing around. We cannot have one foot
in the world and one foot in the church.
We need to be all in for Christ, 100%.
Jesus said, "If you're not with me,
you're against me. There's no gray area.
There's no being on the fence. You're
either 100% sold out for Christ
or you're with the world."
And Jesus says, "Because you're
lukewarm, you're neither hot nor cold,
I'll vomit you out of my mouth." He'll
say, "Many people will say, 'Lord, Lord,
didn't we do all these great things in
your name? We claim to be Christian.'"
He said, "I never knew you. Depart from
me, you workers of lawlessness." Those
of you who are being entertained by the
wickedness of this world.
And Romans 1:32 says, "Not only those
that do such evil acts are worthy of
death, but those who take pleasure in
them that do them." Meaning, you don't
have to practice witchcraft. If you're
being entertained by it, like watching
Harry Potter, you are being entertained
by the things that God calls an
abomination and a sin and wickedness.
You're just as guilty as doing it
yourself because you're taking pleasure
in it.
When we're watching these things, we're
giving our spiritual consent, we're
taking pleasure in them, and it
displeases God, and we will not be found
innocent in the last days. And God is
coming back. Christ is returning looking
for his spotless bride.
And he told a parable of 10 virgins.
And they all fell asleep. All of us have
fallen asleep because Satan as the god
of this world, he's deceived the entire
world, it says.
But
five of those virgins woke up.
They woke up and they had enough Holy
Spirit oil to make it to the wedding.
And they were found worthy to be
accepted by their groom.
And the other five did not. The other
five fell asleep. They didn't have
enough oil. They begged the righteous,
"Please let us have some of yours." And
they said, "We can't give you ours, or
we won't have enough."
Do not be found in that number of
sleeping virgins when we're so close to
the end, guys. There's nothing this
world has to offer that's worth missing
out on what God has to offer us. Eternal
life with him in a perfect kingdom. Not
this satanic world that we're in, this
full of pain and satanic
rituals. I don't want to live here. This
is not my home. I'm longing for the day
he returns, and I pray that you all will
be ready when he comes as well. That's
my prayer.
I love you guys. I thank you guys for
being here. If you want to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We have lots of ways to
give. We have Cash App, Venmo, Zelle,
PayPal, and we even have Patreon. If you
like cool merchandise like the the
hoodie I'm wearing or some of these
t-shirts, we get about $5 on every sale
from these,
and it really helps our ministry. If you
would like to invite us to come to your
event, your school, your youth group,
your church, we will give presentations
at your church. We You can book us on
our website. We would love to come. Last
year was crazy busy. We went all over
the US and even different parts of the
world. We would love to come visit you
and your church.
We cannot do this without you. We thank
you so much for your love and support.
We will see you next time on Candid
Truth.